hey guys welcome to the first 2022
episode of congratulations
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's congratulations
episode two episode whatever it is and
it's 2022
and we are rip roarin and firing on all
syllables that's what we're doing here
at congratulations studios and just keep
in mind that it is 2022 and honestly
we've made it through these past two
crazy years with covet and everything
and you're gonna make it through 2022
and let me just be a little
inspirational for y'all okay because you
know me i can be in i can be
inspirational as all get out
and sometimes i am and i am right now
dude
i want you
to take this
what i'm saying and just write it out
right get on what i'm saying and write
it through
2022 because you already made it you
already made it through the hard parts
okay we're figuring out how to deal with
this coveted [ __ ] and i don't just mean
the actual uh re the the disease i mean
the ramifications of all the other
things too of the shutdowns and the
lockdowns and everybody's pissed and
everyone's upset about how oh we got to
wear a mask or how come we keep locking
down and then we're not locking down
there's red state versus blue state
thinking and but dude we're gonna get
through it okay now all that being said
i got covered
yeah dude i got covered and that's it
i'm done with it i'm already now here's
the deal dude all right i'm on day 14 of
it right now okay and this podcast is
going to come out and i said i got
covered and i'm going to be doing
postings and stuff all over the place on
instagram and [ __ ] tic tac and what
you know your boy goes dummy viral i
went [ __ ] absolutely stupid viral
with my last tech talk and here's the
thing dude all right
first that's not my fault that's up to
the public but here's the thing dude
you're going to see me you idiots are
going to be [ __ ] oh dude but guess
what though you're you're you why aren't
you at home quarantining it's already
over dude okay i recorded this weeks ago
or one week i don't even really
understand when it comes out but dude i
record it and then i and then that's the
thing about i posted a [ __ ] picture
of a positive covid result on my
instagram it was way later and then i
posted a picture of me driving around
and people are like oh dude you're not
taking it seriously you're not
quarantining hey the good thing about
pictures is the reason they exist is so
you can hold on to a moment that was in
the past
okay
when i take a picture i'm holding on to
a moment okay
when i take a picture and i post that
picture it doesn't necessarily mean i
posted the picture as soon as that
moment happened that's the great thing
about pictures we can all agree about
that
pictures or moments in the past pictures
are never
from the future and they're never now
they're never now now it's gone now it's
gone now it's gone now it's gone now's
gone
remember now it's gone
that's the thing about now it's never
now and now it's gone
all right
so everyone stop harping i'm good i'm
clean i'm negative dude i'm good i ca
you know and here's the other thing too
i got that omicron baby
i got that [ __ ] omicron hell
yeah dude i was getting it like it was
out of style went to disneyland don't
think it was that everyone's like well
that's what happens when you go to
disneyland don't think it was from that
went to disneyland with 10 people nobody
got it but me and my [ __ ] immediate
nucleus family
okay
uh and our friend got it too but that's
the other people that we do my mommy my
daddy didn't get it okay my [ __ ] uh
my friends didn't get it nobody got it
their kid didn't get it i think i got it
from i i remember i was talking about it
last time and the thing a guy talked too
close to me a fan got it he must have
gave me omicron dude i tried to back him
up physically i tried to move him like a
chess piece
and the [ __ ] [ __ ] breathed it
into me dude
congratulations the guy's inside me i've
got his omicron so that's great dude i
got your autocraw guy in the blue shirt
in your blue long sleeve shirt i got
your omicron so it's okay
um
here's what happened dude
first day symptom couldn't believe how
tired i was
i couldn't believe how [ __ ] tired i
was i was tired all day and everyone
around me was like yo don't you just
have days where you're just tired all
day nah dude not me now i'm lethargic
right i'm the human garfield and that's
okay
i am
i don't even love lasagna but i'll tell
you i tell you i'm i'm lethargic i'm an
orange cat baby
right
i'm an orange cat with a yellow mouth
who has an owner named john that's me
baby
okay
and so
i um
i was sleeping all day dude all day and
everyone's like it's fine i'm like why
am i so tired everyone's like dude i get
this way
kristen and her friend was she's like we
get this way man some days you just lay
in bed i love those days i was like
really i don't ever lay in bed all day i
never do that and i never lay in bed all
day i don't do that
but i laid on the couch i fell asleep on
the couch i fell asleep on the other
couch oh i've got couches i fell asleep
on all of them dude
okay then i fell asleep in the bad dude
my [ __ ] was out next day woke up felt
great i was like great it's not omicron
felt great
monday did a podcast one fire came over
his girlfriend came over [ __ ]
everyone we kind of hung out had a good
time monday night went to sleep woke up
3am with the goddamn shivers dude the
shivers were unreal the shivers were
unreal
and that's why i didn't warm up dude
okay it's also early we're filming this
podcast early in the day we're not doing
it at night time and that's me with
[ __ ] you know gargly throat waking up
no [ __ ] prep just me singing right
so imagine if i [ __ ]
just did some mayo mayo mayo maze
um
yeah so woke up with the shivers i was
like what the [ __ ] it's so cool now it's
so cool and i'm always cold right so i
get up i'm shivering i walk over to take
a pee i almost faint i pee i have to sit
down i sit down on the floor got a
little bit of nauseous couldn't believe
it thought i was gonna throw up used my
mind to not throw up
okay
i used my mind to not throw up you know
how sometimes you try to force it with
your body you're like come on man and
you're squeezing on and you're holding
on to it you're like in a [ __ ] roller
coaster and you're not sure whether this
[ __ ] this shit's gonna eject from
either end and you're just like come on
force it down i stopped i used my mind
i used my mind i i relaxed i used my
mind
my mind took over i didn't throw up
stood up
right it was like the end of a movie
when batman's badly beaten but you still
know he's the hero
and i shivered all the way back to bed
went back to bed it was like 3 4 a.m
woke up 6 a.m
the bed was a the bed was a puddle the
bed was a pool my fever broke woke up
then at noon
headache central for a whole day
headache central into the next day then
it was fine and i was only nauseous a
little bit and i've been fine ever since
dude then it got bad again like three
days later but i was nauseous felt like
[ __ ] woke up the next day was great was
christmas it was great
omicron i beat omicron dude i did it man
a lot of people probably thought if i
got omicron i might [ __ ] pass away
but i didn't dude i didn't man your boy
was never faced down in a lung machine
or whatever the [ __ ] they put you in but
yeah i'm [ __ ] healthy as [ __ ] dude i
mean that's why i say sorry strong guys
because a lot of strong guys would get
these [ __ ] things and just be out for
days dude your boy wasn't out i
quarantined like a good boy i mean i was
a i was being a good boy having omicron
but dude i was crazy [ __ ] strong so
i'm sorry to break your heart strong
guys speaking of which we got the merch
out there crystallia.com sorry to break
your heart strong guys merch we've got
new colorways at the go medium and
sometimes stay out this [ __ ] is just
[ __ ] drippy dude i'm sorry but the
shit's so drippy we've got the worldwide
life ripper we've got new life rips
[ __ ] um
colorways go go check out crystallia.com
support the show and let them know
[ __ ] life rips especially in 2022
dude we're not letting it get back
downhill you're not gonna let it get
back downhill man
i did some crazy cameos over the past a
lot of people [ __ ] ask me to do
cameos i love it i actually [ __ ] like
it way more than i thought i did and of
course i'm collecting racks and that's
why i'm doing it dude i'm not trying to
pretend i'm connected to my fans i'm
collecting racks
so you get a cameo for me a lot of
people are like my buddy's been through
a rut cheer him up dude i get it man
i get it i connect with you
[ __ ] too dude i look right into
the camera and i feel you man
so anyway i got [ __ ] omicron and it's
all good man
i guess hey dude it's just the [ __ ]
life of an alpha male
it's a [ __ ] life of an alpha male
dude [ __ ] it man goddamn life of a
goddamn alpha male just getting omicron
and just coughing for a day and by the
way i didn't even cough but coffin just
for [ __ ] sake of it you know what i
mean just because everyone you know they
say it's a respiratory thing so i'll
cough i'll give you a little bit omicron
i'll give you a little bit i coughed for
fun a little bit and krista was like oh
my god are you coughing and i'm like i'm
just doing it for omicron's sake
took some [ __ ] woke up at 12 30 every
single day took some [ __ ] dayquil god
it's amazing what dayquil can do
it is
amazing what
dayquil and a little bit of espresso can
just do
when i used to get a cold in my 20s i
used to take dayquil and red bull and my
[ __ ] bro i was [ __ ] i would do that
[ __ ] i would take some dayquil and then
take some [ __ ] a red bull or two and
then immediately just [ __ ]
forget it man i was flying around on
that [ __ ]
i was going nuts i had to do shows with
the flu i'd just be like you know what
give me the [ __ ]
give it to me give me some [ __ ]
dayquil and give me some
espresso
your boy would be in new orleans i
couldn't even hear my [ __ ] act i was
out there talking like charlie brown's
teacher because my [ __ ] was all clogged
up but i took [ __ ] dayquil and
[ __ ] whatever the hell i said uh
some espressos
[Laughter]
i'm faint right now
i'm faint because omicron
and i did that and i'm running out of
breath and it's all good but decor works
so well my buddy tried to be like oh
advoca you know it's actually advil cold
and thymus health because um the the
ingredients in it no dude they quilled
it all the way when some [ __ ] is bright
orange like you know you know it's got
to help right that's why the commercials
for gatorade
you know it's got electrolytes babies
i'm into electrolytes man what can i say
i'm into [ __ ] electrolytes i'm into
orange [ __ ] i'm at the medicine if you
want me to drink a medicine make it
[ __ ] purple or orange otherwise how's
it was it work
i remember one time i did [ __ ] when i
was doing jiu jitsu um my my uh my
sensei's wife
would i brought in red gatorade to drink
after the practice she was like no this
is not good look at this look at this
look what color it is it's not natural
she brought me to the bathroom and
[ __ ] poured it out in front of me and
she was like you don't drink this and i
was like oh okay sorry yeah i guess it's
red left immediately got a [ __ ]
gatorade and that's just the [ __ ]
style i do i i was out 250 because of
her but it doesn't matter man it's
better than [ __ ] arguing and saying
no give me that [ __ ]
right
i'm not i would back then i wasn't a
[ __ ] alpha male but right now the
left of an alpha male you know what i
mean i get omicron and i keep moving
dude
what's the deal with this [ __ ] alpha
i there's this thing i talk about this
out because i just found out about this
alpha con
which is unbelievable i can't believe
they didn't [ __ ] ask me to speak at
it
this is an alphacon thing and i'm
playing i'm going to the website it says
alphacon 2002
22 be great or be nothing wow that's
amazing no that's not true you can also
be fine and just live this is the thing
it's february 18th to 19th
just say february 18th and 19th and
don't act like there's [ __ ] like a
string of days you can go and you can
only go two
um
[Music]
come get some come get real tactical
strategies to scale your business in
2022 attend
as an executive member sign up as if you
ever get alphagun 2002. wow
wow dude
vip two-day event access pass is 3 000
it says almost sold out guarantee it's
not um of course there's a guy with a
mohawk speaking dude how do they not ask
me to speak let's look at this [ __ ]
commercial part
first of all dude it says make sure your
sound is turned on and then it also says
next to it sound have your sound on
twice
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah dude
salt lake city utah who knew
a guy with a [ __ ] faux hawk speaks
speakers include nick sontassen dude
oh wow there's a guy just named brad lee
on it which is secretly just his name is
bradley bradley lee his name is brad
last name lee
that's just bradley dude that's the most
alpha [ __ ] ever your
your whole name
that's like if your name was chester and
your last name was son chester son
jason harward speaking dude wow dude
that one guy's got no arms
jeremiah the bull evans got the fall
keith yaki dude
wow keaton the muscle hoskins oh my god
these guys are these guys are [ __ ]
wider than they are
tall brown
dude
alphacon 2022 what [ __ ] yo hey
hey come on down to alphacon don't bring
your girl oh we are guaranteed the [ __ ]
yo [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah even the guy with no arms oh
straight up [ __ ] your [ __ ] jeremiah the
bull [ __ ] keith yackey and keaton the
muscle of [ __ ] yo [ __ ] consensually
dude the guy with no arms man
there's a guy with no arms
what's his name nick
in salt lake city utah
nick come on nick santon
god for what he lacks in limbs he makes
up for in letters that's for sure
wow dude [ __ ] yeah dude these are the
alpha i need to why didn't they ask me
to speak at this [ __ ] dude speakers
include crystallia i'm coming i'm
[ __ ] coming with my own microphone
nick's intestines
he's lacking liz but he's got the
bladders
and he will [ __ ] your [ __ ] even with
only one leg
[Applause]
yeah dude they do not you go there you
learn nothing straight up dude these are
the other guys names aaron wagner jimmy
rex keaton hoskins bradley the bull
tim ballard
ian went
keith yackey dude i feel like they all
got their names after the first alphacon
they needed to [ __ ] they had regular
names until they [ __ ] just
stepped it up and went to alphacon and
paid three grand for the shits bro i'm
[ __ ] i'm an alpha dude these guys can
i'm gonna start my own [ __ ] you know
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna have a beta
con
i'm gonna have a beta con next to the
alphacon and all we're gonna do you're
gonna pay for a membership and it's
gonna cost some [ __ ] money and all we
do all we do is [ __ ] is go like this
to the alpha con
um
i uh excuse me
oof and we bump into each other and our
papers go you have to bring a bunch of
papers when you get there we give you a
stack of papers and we say have fun and
and there's too many people there
and you bump into each other and the
papers go flying and you go oh my god no
it's okay no don't worry about it it's
okay and you push your glasses up and
you go i'm sorry it was my fault it was
clumsy
the betacon dude and it's that [ __ ]
and it's this [ __ ] uh uh it's this [ __ ]
oh god oh my god i'm so sorry
it's that [ __ ] in the meantime over at
[ __ ] alphacon they're just having a
goddamn field day dude
[ __ ] absolute [ __ ] all the dude
guys don't let your uh women too close
to alphacon we should have we've we
honestly
we should have made it a lot further
away but we're right next door and they
keep on [ __ ] our [ __ ] even the
they keep on [ __ ] our women even the
um what do you call it even the guy with
someone with one limb
how did he get in there
[ __ ] alpha cone
we're [ __ ] old [ __ ]
we [ __ ] [ __ ] your [ __ ] ass no matter
how many lamps we got
[Music]
dude that's all we do
hello here at betacon you will get
direct access and a vip badge on
different classes including looking over
to the side at alphas
make sure
hi
hey what's up my name is um my name is
steven um i'm
the speaker for betacon and i oh god
ouch
excuse me
i don't normally
uh speak in front of this many people um
i can't believe
how many of you there are and um i
appreciate you all oh looks like that
guy dropped his papers um i appreciate
you guys all coming to see me and oops
another guy just dropped his papers he
bumped into somebody
um i i we if we could just practice
looking over at alphacon
make sure you have okay so they're over
there um they're over there having sex
that you can notice them by the
fauxhawks
and they're wider than they are tall and
um just practice holding your chest and
craning your neck and looking
and on your breath say oh my god
if you can hear the music really faintly
if you're listening
alphacon dude
hell yeah dude i need to have [ __ ]
alphacon i need i'm a speaker there
probably if i go there
i'm gonna go there and wear a [ __ ]
black tank top and have a monster energy
drink
how many times
honestly do you think that they say
where's chad people say that in that in
afrikaan um
all right dude
i saw it
i saw the new one matrix um
resonation or resolution or revolution
what the [ __ ] is the
resurrection right resurgence
[ __ ] who knows matrix
resurrection right because it came back
after 20 years
you know
here's what i want to say about it man
i watched it about a week ago
and i saw
how do i start saying this well
i sat with it for a week
i
will say i'll start i'll start it by
saying
how good it is and then i'll go back and
i'll tell you why
the matrix resurrection
is
the
worst movie
that could possibly exist
in
this
time period in this era
the matrix this movie couldn't even have
existed if this era didn't exist the
matrix resurrection is the worst movie i
have ever seen
and it's also
compoundly compoundedly compoundly bad
because of the time that we're in
it is also even more leveled up bad
because of how amazing the matrix is
the matrix
the first one is one of my favorite
movies of all time
it is
top it is top 10 favorite movies of all
time it's so good the way how intricate
it is and how much it creates
a world and then it hears to that world
this is what chowski [ __ ]
killed it dude
it was unbelievable it was so good it
defined a new kind of genre it changed
action movies it changed cinema
now of course the ancillary
uh actors the ancillary characters the
people that they cast did they all look
like they would be in in [ __ ]
they would be poor male porn actors yes
they did does it matter no
every single person in matrix two and
matrix three all the ancillary
characters did it seem like they were
[ __ ] uh male partners yes it did
find one ancillary character in the
matrix two and three that don't look
like they did [ __ ] like they [ __ ]
on other people's [ __ ] tits and faces
and even guys too gay ones too like they
did like straight up like the guy
it's unbelievable how many [ __ ] side
characters in the matrix only look like
[ __ ] porn actors it's male and not
not female but male porn actors straight
and also gay ones dude
it's so crazy
every white guy that they and and also
there's a lot of like mixed race guys
they all look like guys that would just
be like oh yeah and jizz all over
someone else's face whether male or
female okay
i don't know why the wachowski well
sisters did that [ __ ] brothers
i don't want to you know dead name them
god for [ __ ] bid right but they were
back then they well they were they were
they would say that they were women they
just you know had to come out okay fine
but they were still known as the
wateoski brothers back then okay fine
whatever
um
matrix two is horrendous i'm gonna you
know i say matrix three i thought was
great okay matrix one was just all time
two was really bad
three was great that's what i thought
okay
so say what you want about the trilogy
but matrix number one the first one okay
so it was great so
22 years have passed since the matrix
and 60 in the actual world of the matrix
now let me tell you
um
i watched this movie first of all neo's
in therapy in the beginning okay i'm not
going to really do many i'm not going to
do spoilers i'm just going to tell you
about the movie i haven't seen it um but
it's not me who spoiled the movie it's
the movie that spoiled the movie okay
but um
he's in therapy uh which is so weird
also let me tell you this too uh keanu
reeves he's
i you know how much i love counter reefs
i love cannabis i'll watch him in
anything and i will continue to do so
he's just too old dude there was one
time where he was fighting doing the
fight scenes the fight scenes first of
all they're sucked there's no guns in
them which is so weird he did the fight
scene where he was in the middle of
fighting and he got up he used his hand
on his knee to get up okay game over
that's it that's it you're in the matrix
by the way you don't need to use your
knee to get up
your hand on your knee he's too old he
looks weird everybody acts badly in it
neil patrick harris is in it the guy
from [ __ ] mind hunter is in it
they're the new adrian smith and the bad
guy dude it's so weird like neil patrick
harris sure he's a funny actor but he's
the bad guy in the matrix now
bro this is dookiehouser this is the guy
from how i met your mother and he's all
like right neo nah dude
the movie's so colorful and so it's so
here's the thing too it's so of the time
it's so ex you know uh the [ __ ] video
[ __ ] neo works
he doesn't know he's in the matrix any
more and he works and he's famous
because he created a video game called
the matrix and it did so many numbers
because it was basically the movie of
the matrix that he then sold into a
video game and he's working on a new
game and they want to
make him do
the
the sequel to the matrix video game so
it's so super meta but also they're
using footage of the actual movie
as
it being the video game in the matrix
resolution and it's like they're like
well this is the video game that you
made and it's like got keanu reeves and
that [ __ ] chicka place trinity in it
in the [ __ ] video game quote unquote
but they're just showing the movie and
you're watching it and you're just like
hey
that was the matrix the movie though
you're telling me you made this movie it
cost 200 million dollars you couldn't
make a [ __ ] cgi video game version of
the [ __ ] you're just showing the movie
it's so and it's like so like
here's the other thing too
the matrix
i didn't know this back then but when i
saw this you know the wachowski back
then we knew them as the wachowski
brothers they were battling with [ __ ]
inside themselves they believed they
were women they
then uh
uh what do you call it um
changed to women what do you call it
[ __ ] uh
transition to women and and they did
that and
you know [ __ ] good on them man um
and that's awesome and then you watch
the matrix again and you realize that oh
[ __ ] dude this is about
people unplugging from the norms of
society in the real world and finding
out that just because this is what
people say the real world is doesn't
mean that you can't become who you want
to be and live as the one and with and
outside of the matrix it's all a [ __ ]
metaphor for trans politics and there
are people who are trying to like uh you
know stop you and make you feel shitty
about it dude when you watch the matrix
again now
in that lens and i looked it up online
too and they were you know they were
saying that one of the one of the they
wanted one of the actors
to be uh
a male in the matrix and a female
outside the matrix or whatever it was or
i don't know if it was vice versa but it
but but corporate
uh
uh hollywood or corporate america warner
brothers wasn't um ready for that so
they didn't do that and it's like to
make this movie this art
uh
digestible to corporate america and have
it secretly be about
this this this this trans woman's idea
of
what it's like to
be a woman and trapped in a man's body
that is
mind-blowing that is amazing that made
me like the movie even more like they
did that [ __ ] and it was like haha
joke's on you corporate america i'll
make you digest this [ __ ] and this is
secretly about this and then you go and
rewatch it you're like oh you're we may
meme in it you're like oh
that's amazing you did it witchowskis
that was killer [ __ ] it was ahead of its
time and you [ __ ] killed it and
that's what art should be whether or not
you believe a woman was born with a
[ __ ] or not who gives a [ __ ] who cares
that's what art is and you [ __ ]
nailed it i don't care if you think
you're a [ __ ] grilled cheese sandwich
you
nailed it you nailed it
congratulations you're a talent
[ __ ]
blue pill red pill they took that [ __ ]
right
the right took that [ __ ] now they mean
oh you're red pill you're you're waking
up you're seeing what the world actually
is they don't even know what this [ __ ]
means
it was for the left so you bogarted it
fine all good
and then they go and they make this
[ __ ] movie where neo's in therapy and
everything's about your feelings he's
creating a video game called binary and
the matrix
is just like oh my god dude
this is the worst movie i've ever seen
and i hated it because i wanted to want
it to like it i wanted to love it dude
but it's the worst movie and i've seen
wonder woman 84.
that was the worst movie of today wonder
woman 84 and then this movie came out
forget it dude
forget it
the whole movie's so gay ever and i
don't i mean gay everyone in it is is
gay
like agent smith is all that like he's
wearing blue and pink and [ __ ] it's like
what the [ __ ] what what are you doing
there's no guns
not that it's not gay to use not use
guns but dude it's
so badly active even keanu's bad in it
it's all weird as [ __ ] anyway i don't
want to talk about the matrix too much
but i did but
i just don't know what they did movies
are [ __ ] terrible now man
and i'm still a fan of the wachowski
sisters i [ __ ] well only lana did
this one maybe maybe they need maybe she
needs the other one too
oh
and it's so funny too because people are
so afraid to like i looked up at the
onlines that dude there's no way that
anybody in the right mind thinks this
movie is good and like you go to look at
the reviews and ever and people are like
lauding it saying like oh it's so great
because it's so meta and it's speaking
to dude they're only scared to say it's
bad because a [ __ ] trans woman
directed it it's so [ __ ] it's so it's
so ridiculous dude you see the worst
[ __ ] out in hollywood and they're just
people are scared like god forbid
somebody would review an all-black cast
in a bat you they can't do it no matter
how bad that you can't i'm saying the
the audience score fine but the [ __ ]
critics dude they won't review an
all-black cast or something directed by
a trans woman they just won't review it
[ __ ]
it's just unbelievable
it's so [ __ ] hilarious and i'm not
saying that some of these don't deserve
it they do but it's just so weird man
everyone's so scared dude
i watched that shang chi movie it was a
piece of [ __ ] garbage dude
it was garbage
and and i looked at the [ __ ] critics
it was 100 everyone so scared because of
the stop age and hate [ __ ]
dude it's garbage
it's so bad
at least 50 percent like maybe i don't
like it because that's not for me but
like a hundred percent
a hundred percent of critics liked it a
hundred percent of critics liked it a
hundred percent of critics they don't
like [ __ ] the godfather
and this is how this is the greatest
movie of all time
it's so weird it's so weird and i will
say dude
you know the people even the users on
rotten tomatoes like they're all [ __ ]
like 12 year olds and and and there's
them and and you know
oh dude it's just so weird man
i'm getting too serious didn't mean to
get too serious
all good
but this is why i need to [ __ ] speak
at alphacon
because i'm a serious [ __ ] with
tmj disorder
um
my son is [ __ ] hilarious dude
for some reason like he just
he just started saying
i did it
that's it that's all he ever says now i
did it
it's the cutest [ __ ] thing
he shoveled i put it on instagram he
shoveled his [ __ ] food under his tray
and like it went under his tray into
where his seat was in the high chair and
he was and he said
that's what he does for all don
and i said oh did you eat it all and he
says i did it i said you ate it all i
did it and then i [ __ ] it's all in
his chair
but i don't even think he knows what
he's saying
because i walked in this morning when he
when he woke up to go get him out of the
bed out of his crib and i said hey buddy
did you have a good sleep and he said i
did it
and i'm like it kind of makes sense but
also are you just saying the thing that
you learned
i'll be like are you hungry and he'll be
like i did it
it's so [ __ ] funny and so cute
he goes like this off off see off off
off
and then he says
and he says
because he wants to watch his eyes he
wants to read his i spy book
book
god dude he's never gonna shut up huh
i did it already starting to take credit
for [ __ ] that he didn't even [ __ ] do
it was it me
who's he me
i did
gorgeous boy i love him
he is so funny dude
boy he's doing smelly [ __ ]
just like his dad
um
yeah man
but what got heated there i'm sweating
but it's all good
my jaw hurts
you know thanks for being with me you
guys
greatest podcast of all time you guys
know it i i asked you guys everyone
listening send it to somebody
who
uh
hasn't heard the podcast yet we need to
grow this cult dude we really need to
grow this cult because this is a cult
man and if you think that i will not get
a log cabin in the goddamn metaverse
you're insane i'm gonna have a log cabin
in the metaverse we're all gonna have
our [ __ ] avatars or whatever the hell
you call it we're going to be able to go
there and share ideas in the tall
virtual grass and i'm going to be able
to do that and i'm going to go and i'm
going to chill there i'm going to live
there in the metaverse and i'm going to
do that
in the metaverse and not in real life so
whoever goes that's secretly crazy can't
stab me if you want to stab him you got
to stab me in the metaverse
right enemies can come stab me in the
metaverse that's the thing about this
it's going to be exclusive
and uh you're going to be able to come
if you're one of those [ __ ] if you
got one of those you know what dude
anytime i see anything about an nft or a
metaverse on instagram or anywhere on
tiktok or in the news or anything i
sincerely have a low-grade panic attack
like i genuinely don't know what they're
talking about dude i saw this [ __ ]
thing
oh wait i did it he doesn't say i did it
he says yeah it did that's what he says
yeah i did my son says yeah i did that's
what he says i said do you have a good
night's sleep yeah i did and then i said
did you eat all your things yeah it did
that's what it does not yet i knew it
was funnier than that yeah it did wow i
[ __ ] it all up told the wrong story of
my podcast yes dude
forgot it already and it's [ __ ] the
love of my life from my son ah yes
but yeah anytime i see a metaverse thing
i get look like dude the [ __ ] that this
[ __ ] metaverse like look at what this
let me see if i can find it
yeah i did
yeah i did that's so cute dude
like look at what these things do like
what they say like look at this just
look at this title dude i follow
hypebeast on ins on instagram
and this is the thing that it says on
the picture okay first of all it says
another it says another board ape mega
mutant serum sold for 3.6 million
dollars okay
so first of all what does it mean okay
uh just for the third word in what does
it mean
another board ape what does it mean mega
mutant serum what does it mean sold for
3.6 million dollars what does it mean
okay because you know there's no mega
mutant serum in real life so what does
it mean right is it an nft is it in the
metaverse whatever so we read the
[ __ ] thing and this is what it says
another board ape yacht club mega mutant
serum has sold for 999 eth which is 3.6
million usd what does it mean what does
it mean what does it mean what does it
mean
the purchase was made by current mega
mutant holder oxb1
oh what does it mean okay who has an
estimated net worth or more
450 million
usd
okay fine i know what that means this
purchase follows the recent
mega 88.88 serum sale by
ethereum co-founder ah what does it mean
what does it mean what does it mean what
does it mean okay
so what does all this [ __ ] mean
i mean dude
look at this [ __ ]
look at this the 10th and there's
another thing by hypebeast the 10th mega
mutant ape has been unveiled
ethereum co-founder taylor gehring just
applied his mega mutant serum
do i have a full i have like a [ __ ]
low-grade paddock attack for this [ __ ]
what am i missing out on like what's
happening
okay
uh just applied his co-founder just
applied his mega mutant serum which he
purchased for 888 eth roughly 3.6
million yesterday the mega mutant serum
is part of the board ape chemistry club
which consists of ten thousand mutant
serums that were given to all board
yacht board ape yacht club
the serums broken up into three tiers
called m1m2 and mega mutant can then
transform existing apes into mutant
versions of themselves and are burned
upon use
there are three more mega mutant serums
left and have already received a bit of
999 eth dude what these
it says
mega mutant can transform existing apes
into mutant dude what do you mean
existing they don't exist
i need to get digital real estate dude
i'm getting really i'm getting real
estate i'm getting a log cabin i'm
talking to the [ __ ] nft creator i
already talked to the [ __ ] guy i'm
getting i'm getting actual i'm getting a
log cabin i got his number i'm texting
him right now for real
i gotta send him a number actually
because i already been texting him but
then he said he
here we go
here's my number sending him my his
number right now
here we go
cool
yeah i did
yeah i did yeah i did
um anyway dude
[ __ ] this goddamn nft [ __ ] dude i gotta
get on this [ __ ]
um
what else dude i wanted to talk about
this i saw this movie fat man the
christmas movie with mel gibson it's so
good dude it's so funny
it's so good and it's so funny man and
that's it it's a drama and they do it
like a drama it's about a kid that wants
to [ __ ] kill santa so he puts out a
hit on santa for giving him coal and it
sounds like a comedy and i guess
technically it is but it's so real and
it's they do it so real and it's funny
as [ __ ] dude
um and that's it that's all i wanted to
say about that um uh uh sorry guys my
son woke up i had to get him uh so we
cut for a second but it'll seem like no
time for you which actually leads me to
this i forgot to even talk about this
but oxnard i'll be uh at oxnard
california doing the crystalia and
friends
stand-up shows um at uh oxnard uh at the
oxnard improv you can go and get tickets
it's in it's in california it's like an
hour at la actually not even but uh you
can go get tickets at crystallia.com
uh i'm just starting to get back out
there on the road and uh
go before it sells out uh unless it
already is i actually have no idea but
um
yeah so that's that
uh look forward to seeing you there
[ __ ] this omicron [ __ ] you know what i
mean
i'm going to do this good vibe segment
which is cute as [ __ ]
i do this new segment called the good
vibe
segment
this autistic boy's reaction to his
christmas present
this kid likes loud [ __ ]
when your brother who is autistic loves
anything loud and gets a homemade train
horn gun for christmas wow that family's
gonna
regret that
he's so happy dude
jumping up and down because the train
horn
they say do it outside they don't want
to do it inside because of course it's
gonna be still there but he's so happy
jesus christ
[Music]
wow
oh my god
okay the dad did it now he's doing it
they said one time
wow
dude and he will be
ten minutes later and he's still
laughing dude
wow i wish i liked something this much
this is awesome dude
god christmas is awesome oh [ __ ]
awesome if you're autistic
do you just get a loud thing [ __ ] man
god how ab by the way how [ __ ]
annoyed is that family the neighbors are
going to be so annoyed wow i can't even
keep this a [ __ ] good vibe segment it
was beautiful that it happened and it is
beautiful and i love that boy and i love
that family for doing that and treating
it [ __ ] well it was so nice but but
god damn that [ __ ] neighbors
the kids gonna be outside just young
young people going to be like i don't
live near a train god damn it
just jumping up and down in the [ __ ]
street
an autistic boy just with the train horn
goddamn although he obeyed with the one
time they said one time he did it one
time he said that was awesome and then
ran inside and was [ __ ] laughing
about how loud it was
man if i could [ __ ] calvin already is
doing
[ __ ] like
disobeying
calvin is already doing stuff he's lying
in my face about did you eat did you
finish eating it's down his pants yeah i
did
smuggling [ __ ] potatoes
let's do some misconnections babies
love these misconnections well guys it's
time for the next segment miss
connections
where'd you go looking for my straight
buddy silma all of them are in sylmar
santa clarita i'm looking for my chill
straight bro
so right down to it we'd hang out and
have fun once in a while
wow
he had a nice package for me to open are
you down to meet up
wow
unreal
i'm looking for my chill straight bro
hey guy
you're not straight what is this [ __ ]
thing that like
some gay guys i guess don't want to
admit that they're gay and they're just
straight
and they're like yeah i'm straight but
like i'll i'll jerk you or some [ __ ]
it's like yeah just so you know i'm
straight but
i'll suck you but i don't want it but
i'll suck you hey
hey
you're gay it's all good
you're gay
what world am i offending anyone by the
way
because we probably in 2022 it probably
the time where you can be
straight and also do gay [ __ ] but still
identify as straight yeah i identify as
straight but i suck [ __ ]
and people will still be like no if
that's what he identifies as then he's
straight but like but i saw him sucking
[ __ ] he's sucking cockry he's sucking
your [ __ ] right now well if that's what
he's that's what just what gays are are
banning together to because they're just
getting more bj's out of it
no and look if he's straight then he's
straight now
suck me off
ah there we go great good there we go
okay but i'm straight yes no i know if
you identify as straight that's good
about to come
all in your mouth and there we go good
straight guy good go play football
and gay guys are just saying this to
trick us i'm not falling for it dude i'm
sucking off no guys
hey wait a minute imagine having a [ __ ]
in your mouth and being like wait a
minute
did you just splirt down my throat hold
up hold on one goofy second
you know
wait a second just jerking i'm straight
i know okay wait a minute
splurt wait a second splurt all hold on
a second uh wait a minute ropes in your
face
one goofy second jerking off two guys in
the back of a taxicab okay just so you
know i'm straight really yeah wait a
second multiple [ __ ] different
from different sides ropes ropes in your
face from different sides hold on one
goofy second ropes down your throat
like how are these guys getting away
with tricking us that we're [ __ ]
straight when we're taking ropes in the
face dude
you're digging ropes in the face you're
gay
[Music]
one rope
two ropes
god damn
sure you are buddy ropes ropes ropes
it's like get out of here man [ __ ]
goofy barbells all in your face you know
those [ __ ] swivel ones that
those goofy [ __ ] barbells
you ever smash those goofy barbells out
of your
[ __ ] bottom nose
dude
those [ __ ] goofy barbells just
whipping around
ropes in your face goofy barbells in
your face dude
just [ __ ] yeah dude
um
yeah how do they do that how did they do
that that was like when black people
took the n-word and started using it
themselves how did gays do that they
convinced us that we're straight but gay
wow i mean i've never done it but you
know what i'm saying
um
god man
we'd hey looking for my straight because
that's the thing dude gays want to be
like they want some sneaky [ __ ] over
it's like yeah you're still straight
gotcha that's what turns them on about
it right that's what turns them on about
it yeah no no worries you're still
straight and in in their [ __ ] gay
mind they're like
[Laughter]
this is my kink i tricked you goofy
barbell
goofy goofy roped barbell in your face
wow dude
i'm being funny uber here's another one
uber driver from guatemala who plays
violin
specific an evil villain
an evil [ __ ] villain
i mean
an uber driver from that would be like
in [ __ ] hollywood it's like and who's
the bad guy well he's an uber driver
from guatemala who plays a violin and
he's looking for one of the avengers
i like it i like it people that amplin i
like it i like it
people like castle rock entertainment
okay i'm on board
if your name starts with a j and you
also play the violin eh sir weird
specific kink i'd like to talk to you
i'm sorry i jumped out the car so
quickly i was late to work
wow unreal dude
i'd like to talk to you i was late for
i'd like to shoot some goofy barbells in
your face uh here's here's another one
god damn it dude we gotta get to the
metaverse asian studies teacher
i miss door open waiting downward on the
couch for robert
he didn't have to say asian studies
teacher it's a apparent that you have
problems speaking english and you're
asian with this body i miss door open
waiting downward on the couch for robert
also
worst
asian studies teacher that he's [ __ ]
trying to put him face down you know
hi
would you like to learn english
oh step one
face down about to shoot some goofy
barbells on your back
here's another one me banjo player you
cute caveman what's up with the [ __ ]
instruments on this one dude they play
[ __ ] uh violin or banjo
this is another batman villain hi i was
playing banjo outside of the grocery
store and when by the way this guy's the
most annoying who's playing banjo
outside of a go you better been working
for what what do you call it uh
salvation army and dressed as santa and
dressed as mexican santa is
dressed as ecuadorian santa otherwise
i'm pissed hi i was playing banjo
outside of the grocery store and when i
saw you we spoke just a little lil i
wish i wished i asked you what your name
was i believe you has a yellow sweater
on with blonde hair live to love thanks
for reading
wow yellow sweater with blonde hair this
guy's
really pushing it huh
guy play imagine seeing outside of a
[ __ ] grocery store a guy playing a
banjo talking to a guy with a yellow
sweater and blonde hair
i would immediately [ __ ] jump off a
building that's too much for my for me
to take anr here's another one i miss
you in many ways when we connect it's
total silence and bliss please share and
nurture
huh
sh please share and nurture i miss you
in many ways when we connect it's total
silence and bliss well you don't miss
him in the talking ways you want him to
[ __ ] keep
oh it's an adult nursing relationship
what the [ __ ]
like that's their nurse like they're an
old person or like you
is that a sexual kink thing dude i need
to get i need to get in i need to learn
what the kinks are a little bit more
i have no ideas what a i have no idea
it's a kink okay adult nursing
relationship let's look what it is
adult
nursing wow my google history is going
to be [ __ ] up
relationship well it doesn't pop up even
on google which means that wow dude it's
really here we go adult nursing
relations inside the ms oh inside the
misunderstood world of adult bread
breast feeding wow
look at the things that people also
people also ask can i breastfeed my
husband without being pregnant
can you breastfeed a grown man is it
okay for adults to drink breast milk
your dad died early if that's your kink
uh inside the misunderstood world of
adult breastfeeding wow this is from
rolling stone look at the art that is
just a [ __ ] husband holding the wife
up
while he's breastfeeding her
editor's note i love this some names in
this story have been changed at the
request of the interview subjects yeah
no [ __ ] man
nobody wants to be hi i'm an adult i
love sucking on tits for milk
ellie and garrett have been together for
six years they have a clear affection
for each other touching each other
gently on the shoulder when one says
something to the other
says something that the other
appreciates and
often looking at each other lovingly
throughout conversation their respect
and adoration for one another comes
through even over a skype call
from their home in queensland australia
yeah adults suck titties in the street
and for milkiness in queensland
australia their home happens
why am i getting an ad here
their home happens
their home appears cozy and comfortable
in garrett
intense households they also engage in
what they call feeding
wow that's some alien [ __ ]
kind of hot if they love it if they love
it it's hot you know what i mean this ad
dude get out of here with this [ __ ]
ad
um
55 and 57
in what's known as an adult nursing
relationship or an adult breastfeeding
relationship these arrangement these
arrangements are exactly what they sound
like one partner produces milk to share
with the other throughout
through breastfeeding how do you
breastfeed if you're 57 for many there's
a sexual aspect to the nursing part of
the relationship but adult nursing
relationships are not
strictly sexual
on the one social media site phet life
sounds kinky which serves people
interested in bdsm and kink a few
thousand
users discuss how they simply enjoy the
act of suckling
by the way dude can can't we just use
the word sucking
suckling is like why did you add an l to
it it basically means the same thing
let's just use suckling
let's just use sucking suckling as gross
as [ __ ]
are you into dick sucking well dick
suckling
enjoy the act of suckling or exchanging
milk while cuddling
ew dude the way they it's so clinical or
watching tv on some nights god imagine
watching [ __ ] homeland and you're
just like you mind if i pop down get
some milk sweetie
do you mind if i start some suckling
while you watch jack bauer try to save
the world
the dynamics of these relationships can
be incredibly varied and they are not
limited to heterosexual pairings
there are many women who enjoy the act
of suckling a partner too well one
thing's for sure two dudes can't do it
unless you're doing it from your [ __ ] hi
i'd like to suckling milk from from your
[ __ ]
yeah yeah i'd like to do some suckling
on your [ __ ] okay i'm straight by the
way sure you are buddy
let's do it add up in your in your gay
mind yeah
that a boy
yeah
get those goofy barbells out
um
wow man let me tell you something right
now uh what do you call it [ __ ]
craigslist is off the [ __ ] chain
here's another one
melee
kalikimaka up the road a bit okay the
most hawaiian [ __ ] sounding [ __ ] of
all time mele
uh merry christmas to the girl who i'm
whom i've compared all others for what
seems like forever now not a sentence of
everything i've lost in my life losing
you was the longest lasting and most
impactful thing don't get in touch i'd
be
don't be in t don't get in touch i'd be
too nervous just smile for me please wow
so
trying to take back the control
in his own way but also needs to go to
betacon for real dude because that is
sad as [ __ ]
this guy's the [ __ ] lead guy and take
me home tonight
hope for grace and take me home tonight
for where he's like such a [ __ ] but
he's like
yeah i was too nervous to ever talk to
you and now that i'm adult i'm still
kind of too nervous to ever talk to you
if you've ever seen that movie that's
what this guy is
tell for grace
and take me home tonight
with that chick in the [ __ ] movie
take me home tonight who isn't the girl
from twilight yeah okay she's basically
just i can't believe it that girl what's
her name in the [ __ ] take me home
tonight take
me
home
tonight
movie
cast
who is this chick and how is she not
theresa palmer how is she not the girl
from twilight she's hot girl hot version
of girl from twilight teresa palmer
julia's so hot
and then she's also
is it kristen stewart
stewart
yeah
she's her only the hotter version
sorry for saying that if i'm if that's
dick
um anyway dude i'm done thank you so
much you guys are amazing uh and
remember uh go to my website
crystalia.com for tour dates on oxnard
uh you can go uh get those tickets and
keep up uh wearing those merches
at other people's shows i see you guys
when you repost the stuff at different
people's shows all the other comedians
you wear those [ __ ] and you
represent the cult we got to get in that
metaverse dude and build that virtual
log cabin never realized that the lag
cabin was always supposed to be virtual
with my babies but we're going to share
ideas and that's that hey guys that's
the podcast for today on youtube if you
want to get the rest of the podcast
uncut uh with no ads or commercials go
to patreon.comcrystalia
support the show you get multiple
episodes that are not available to the
public on our patreon i think there's
like 12 there now
and where every month we have a new one
uh it's six dollars a month you get
another i do another segment called
review set review mode which i review
different things anyway
it supports us it supports the podcast
it keeps it keeps the podcast going and
we're able to do this and uh
and that's that so thanks very much
patreon.comcrystalia
have a good one
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
thank
you everybody are they ready babe give
them a thumbs up